hey guys what's up this is andrew for
trendsenses.com so as usual
let me introduce myself for those who
are watching my video for the first time
i've been working as a professional
trader for the past six years in hong
kong and i use technical analysis and
other
information like the volume short
interest or the option market everything
that they can find at the option market
to build up my view so i'm here to show
you how i do it
and how to do it yourself so today let's
see what technical analysis is telling
us for gamestop let's get into it
[Music]
all right guys so this is my uh gamestop
chart
as usual we're going to start on the
forward step frame then we're going to
zoom in a little bit
see if we find any signals on the
shorter time frame like the hourly time
frame which is very good to use as well
and we're gonna try to see what might
happen next
so last week i told you guys that i've
discovered something that is
actually for me the key to understanding
what these games stop
doing and what will probably happen
within one or two weeks so i was trying
to understand
this complex correction that we're
having since we reached the 340 level
so this is the second high which is the
lower high by the way
and we are still we are since the tenth
of march
uh correcting in a kind of messy way so
some of you are telling me that
this is because this market is
manipulated what this means is that
basically and
i think it is true you know but i i
don't have any information about that so
that's why i'm not taking
this into account in my analysis but
there is a lot of
trades that are done in some dark pools
that are involving like big investors
that don't want
to actually disturb the market and to
pass their big sizes on the exchange
so this has always been happening but
what might happen
is some maybe naked shorts which is
illegal
that might happen as well in this dark
pulse and to be
very honest with you guys i'm not aware
about what is
going on exactly with the stock but what
i can only tell you
is that indeed there are some movements
some behaviors that are to me not really
expected for example on the daily time
frame
as you can see here the magnitude
positive
let's see so i added here guys i'm going
to show you this very soon
the realized volatility you're going to
see how we can use it i'm going to
explain what it is it's not an indicator
that a lot of traders are using but i'm
an option trader
so it's something that i look at every
day when i'm at work
so i'm gonna come back to this very soon
but first let's have a look guys
at the magdy all right so i'm sorry i
have now a lot of
indicators so here is the volume and
my second one that is here is the macd i
told you guys
so on the daily time frame that once the
macd has turned positive
which was here on the 28th of april we
should have
a bullish cycle that would last around
three weeks you know one month as it
used to you know
in the past in the three past month but
here
the macd turned positive and four days
later it turned
negative so this is why we didn't have
the third ways i was i was expecting and
we are having a more complex correction
and maybe because you know there are
some selling pressures that
are happening on the side market like
dark pools
i don't know i don't know but what i
know is that still
this is a complex correction that is
where we can find
a valid counting and apply idiot wave
theory so this is what i'm gonna stick
to
this is what i'm gonna try to do and to
be very honest with you guys what i
found here
looks very good to me even if it's messy
even if there are some moves that you
know are not
very clean and i don't perfectly
understand the outcome to me
is very clean actually so let me repeat
what i see here
so i'm gonna go back on the flowers time
frame to have
more details about the moves that we had
here
so maybe just very quickly i'm gonna
explain what i'm trying to do so here
the first move that went to 480 was one
wave then we had a correction and i'm
trying to
basically guess when the this market
would start to be bullish again so i'm
trying to find when this complex
correction is going to end
so to do that the first thing you need
to be able to do is to
find a proper counting here that is
respecting all the idiot wave theory
rules
uh and so after doing that i would be
able to know when
it's finished and so here actually what
we're having
is uh definitely a triangle that is
quite easy to see
here we're having this abc and some of
you were telling me yeah but i was
saying in my previous video that it's uh
abc
then a triangle and then we're gonna
move up and i received some comments
that were actually
quite good they were telling me uh bro
you're forgetting the y
wave because it's w x y that's true but
you know it doesn't change
anything because i can do it this way
you know instead of starting my triangle
here
i can just turn my triangle here and do
my abcde
and here actually the first the a wave
of of my triangle is actually a zigzag
and you are right guys it's good to do
things properly
but idiot also as you can see here guys
so this is the idiot wave
uh pdf that you can find on google just
type idiot wave
theory and go to the second link and
open this
and you're gonna find here that idiot is
talking about
double three and triple threes so for
example you can see here
all right idiot called sideways
combination of corrective patterns
double
threes and triple threes so you can have
a double three
but i agree that even when you have a
double three
you usually have a zigzag between the
two threes so here my first three is a
zigzag
my second three is a triangle so i need
to have a zigzag
in between so it's actually better to
label
it this way and by doing so i have
actually
one more wave which is the e wave here
that is going to be a wave that is going
down
and after that i could have my one two
three four five starting so it makes
more sense
so let's keep it this way so what i want
to tell you here guys is that when i do
this
you know as clean as i can so let's go
on to hourly time frame
you can see that so there is a double
sloping trend line here so it's the
upper band of my triangle
it's not this one it's here so let me
get rid of the wxy you guys saw it all
right
and here the upper band is going down
and the lower band is going
up which is good about that is that
actually that co
they are converging towards the
intersect that is
on the 20th of may so if this is correct
and i truly believe that this complex
correction
is going to happen this way and then
it's gonna be over guys
so this is correct what i can tell you
is that
before the 20th of may and i would say
maybe around the 17th so you know
something like this we're gonna have
this strong move up that is gonna come
so
of course i'm gonna keep an eye on it
i'm gonna update you guys if i see
anything that goes in the
wrong direction but for now this is what
we're having
let's analyze very quickly what happened
in the recent past
in the recent past what did we have so
we are supposed to get
uh this d wave that is starting right
now
and you can see that here the price
action
is not only supported by the lower burn
of my triangle but we also have the 200
period moving average that is on the
four hours time frame
so best moving average best time frame
so good
signal that was giving us a buying
signal on 23rd of april
and all this consolidation area is
actually supported not only by the
lower band of my triangle which could be
like this
all right doesn't change much but also
by this 200 period moving average so
this
gives you some hints about where this
low
would have happened before it actually
happens
so right now what are we expecting let
me zoom in
a little bit more so i think it's the
time for me to tell you about
the volatility guys so let me get rid of
the macd
then here look at this
so let me take a step back
so just look at this lines that are here
so you have many of them
but you have the 5 15 30 and 60 days
realized volatility so it's basically
giving you
the average move that gamestop is doing
during this time so you can see that the
five days moving average which is a
weekly realized volatility
is the one that is moving the faster and
it's very interesting to notice that you
have cycles in the price action but you
also have cycles in the realized
volatility of
the price action and here we can see
that it
buttoned for the past three months it
was bottoming at 30 right
right now the realist volatility look at
this
number here is at 46
and the bottom of it is yeah 30
25 you know something like this so what
i expect
in terms of volatility guys and then
we're gonna see how
this gives us information for the press
action in terms of volatility expect
something like this
maybe and then we go higher again you
know
and we we do the cycles and i i don't
know exactly
what is going to be the next cycle but
what i know is that
we're not gonna stay here long you can
see that we were here
you know maximum one or two days here as
well here as well here as well
here we came back and then went higher
but ultimately
gamestop is going to start moving
strongly again
so now why is the realist volatility
that low
is because we are in a consolidation
area so it's
very usual it's very normal we're gonna
have
probably i think it's it's almost done
so the d
wave is coming it's gonna be bullish
we're probably gonna take
back the pivot level that is at 173 guys
i told you many times about this level
that it's very important for me
you can see that how many reactions we
had in the past and the sideways
correction is actually centered on this
level
so this is the level above which we are
bullish below which we are bearish
here we are just moving sideways so
bullish bearish bullish bearish
you know in the short term it's like i
said very messy
but what we can see is that probably
this on the short term guys i'm giving
you short term and long term views
together but on the short term
we are almost done with this
consolidation
and you can even zoom in a little bit
and apply the method i gave you many
times guys
so you just connect you know when you
find a wave that's why it's good to
label it when you find a wave so here
my c wave can be actually
used to make a trendline like this all
right
you see and once you have this trendline
that is broken on the upside
so i'm gonna remind you again what
broken means you need to have two
consecutive candles
before that are trading above the trend
line you are considering
so that you can call it a confirmation
and you can say that the trend line is
broken once it's broken if you guys want
to buy
i don't like to buy the breakout some
traders do it
but i don't like it because you don't
know where you should
really put your stop-loss so i like to
buy the re-test
so this level for example you have to
break at around 165 for example on
monday if you trade
at 165 at the open this is very bullish
so we might go up stride right away but
most likely we're gonna correct a little
bit re-test
those levels around the 160 and then go
higher
right and then do the same thing with
this 175 level
so very quickly guys how we usually
break
those levels we're going to arrive get
rejected take
energy break it retest it and go higher
all right this is the typical
breakout that would probably happen
around this level as well
so if you want to trade it this is what
you need to look for
you come here you can buy the retest
here i mean it's even before the
breakout you can buy this consolidation
zoom in a little bit
and do the same kind of exercise i did
with you here
so you wait for a breakout on the
shorter time frame and you buy the
re-test
you zoom in you're going to five minutes
time frame if you want to do this like
for this
kind of short small moves so i think i'm
done
here so i'm gonna just repeat quickly
what i said
so on the fullest time frame we are
supported by the 200 period moving
average we are supported by the lower
band of my triangle
if this breaks guys careful it means
that
something else is playing out but
definitely it would mean that we
might have one more corrective pattern
before going
higher this is not my preferred scenario
but i need to
be professional and to talk about it as
well my preferred scenario is that
as you can see the press action is
bullish here the volatility realized
volatility is about to burst
and usually it's gonna you know give us
information that
we're gonna do a new like there's gonna
be a reversal so here
the reversal of the c wave would be the
d wave all right and then we would do
the e-wave
and then guys we're gonna do the
third wave finally and this one is gonna
be very interesting to see very
interesting to analyze for me so i'm
gonna follow this closely of course
but we have until the 20th of may before
all of this happens
so that's it for me i hope you guys
enjoyed this video and if you did please
don't forget to click on the sub
like and that button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to show i'll see you
guys